okay let's get into some of the recent
political stories a lot of stuff
happened over the vacation that I want
to talk about and some of the things
that happened we will talk about today
and others we will catch up on during
during the week we know that Donald
Trump generally cannot stay on script
and in fact it could even be argued that
the entire Russia investigation as it
exists today only exists because of
Trump going off-script extraneous
unnecessary tweets unnecessary firings
whatever so long story short it's bad
when Trump isn't as controlled as
possible by staff which is only at best
ever a moderate level of control well at
mar-a-lago during our end-of-the-year
break were Trump obviously where else is
Trump going to be at the end of the year
or at any time other than his own clubs
and playing golf at his own Golf Club
they call it the winter White House down
there yeah although it's never really
winter down there interestingly enough
anyway a club member named Christopher
ruddy introduced Trump to a New York
Times reporter named Michael Schmidt at
mar-a-lago and it led to a totally
impromptu interview that the White House
had no idea Trump was actually doing the
New York Times actually quoted a trump
White House official who was asked about
Trump's interview with the New York
Times and the Trump White House official
responded what interview today
another official called the total lack
of organization and coordination for
this interview quote embarrassing now
you might be saying what happened in the
interview because unless Trump said
something that was embarrassing it's not
really an embarrassment well it was
really really bad in this interview
again impromptu interview at his Golf
Club White House staffers knew nothing
about it Trump told the New York Times
reporter that he has the quote absolute
right to do whatever he wants about the
robert muller russia investigation he
started talking completely incoherent ly
about russia democratic collusion I
guess the idea is if you lie big enough
at least in the minds of some it becomes
the truth and Schmidt rightly tried to
ask him hey you said that the
investigation would be over by now and
it isn't what about that and Donald
Trump comes up with this just a beauty
to quote Trump himself that it's
actually the Democrats that colluded
with Russia let's look at a bit of a
transcript from this interview Schmidt
says but in terms of the lawyer said it
would be done by your guy said it would
be done by Thanksgiving it would be done
by Christmas what are they telling you
now what are they telling you and Donald
Trump said there was tremendous
collusion on behalf of the Russians and
the Democrats there was no collusion
with respect to my campaign I think I'll
be treated fairly timing wise I can't
tell you I just don't know but I think
we'll be treated fairly later in their
in the same interview Trump went back to
this idea yet again another piece of the
interview Donald Trump saying but there
is tremendous collusion with the
Russians and with the Democratic Party
including all of the stuff with the and
then whatever happened to the Pakistani
guy that had the - you know whatever
happened to this Pakistani guy who
worked with the DNC then possibly the
crowning moment of the interview as a
sort of authentically Trump interview he
did one of his total word salad rants to
try to explain away the entire Russia
investigation along with the four
indictments to date as phony and a
Democratic cover-up for Hillary Clinton
losing this will sound like a run-on
mess when I read it to you and it is
it's I just want to want you to know
this is what Trump said it's not me
messing up the read of it okay
during the interview Trump says so for
the purposes of what's going on with
this phony Russian deal which by the way
you've heard me say it is only an excuse
for losing an election that they should
have won because it's very hard for a
Republican to win the electoral college
okay you start off with New York
California and Illinois against you that
means you have to run the East Coast
which I did and everything else which I
did and then won Wisconsin and Michigan
so the Democrats they thought there was
no way for a Republican not me a
Republican to win the electoral college
well they're inaudible they made the
Russians story up as a hoax as a ruse as
an excuse for losing an election that in
theory Democrats should always win with
the electoral college the electoral
college is so much better suited to the
Democrats
but it didn't work out that way and I
will tell you they cannot believe that
this became a story anyway it goes on
and on I encourage you to check it out
but it's understandable why the White
House is embarrassed about this and
there's other stuff in there Pat about
tax cuts that's just as silly as you
would imagine but my takeaway is first
of all there is huge risk to Trump
hanging out at his golf clubs because he
ends up in these unplanned and
uncontrolled interviews with newspapers
like the New York Times which isn't good
and we have to assume that there is an
effort being made to control him at the
golf clubs but that any moment where
he's uncontrolled he can't help but run
his mouth like this well I don't know I
mean it's an interesting tidbit that
this took the White House by surprise
that they know the interview was going
to happen sure but it's not like if he
had known ahead of time he would have
been prepared and whatever spoken
eloquently we've seen this before no I
think it's more that the damage control
apparatus might have been more prepared
if the White House had known ahead of
time but yeah you're right it's not like
Trump would have in an incredibly
graceful and articulate articulate way
explained his position on the Russia
investigation any bits about him with
his lawyers or something right something
yeah or or maybe have put out some
tweets in advance of the interview going
out there preemptively discrediting the
failing New York Times
welcome to 2018 is the message and it's
going to be a very very interesting year
the video you just watched was made
possible by support from you please go
to patreon.com slash david pakman show
you can make a pledge of as little as $1
per month and every dollar helps to
support the work that we're doing
particularly in light of the YouTube ad
boycott which has been really bad